los ataques constantes contra toresk no
impiden que Alexandra tiende a sus
clientes como de costumbre en las
últimas semanas la guerra ha afectado su
vida como no lo había hecho desde 2014
cuando la ciudad quedó ubicada pocos
kilómetros del frente entre el ejército
ucraniano y las fuerzas separatistas
apoyadas por Moscú que desde entonces
tenían el control de una franja del
Pero cómo puedo abandonar esto es todo
lo que hemos acumulado en la vida
su marido que trabajaba en una mina
local Fue llamado a integrarse al
ejército hace pocas semanas y sus dos
hijas dejaron la ciudad huyendo de la
guerra solo la acompañan sus dos gatos
si algo le pasa a mi marido no tendré
Cómo apoyar a mi hija de 16 años que
necesita de mí Ella se fue de aquí
completamente sola a una ciudad que ni
siquiera conocía del Oeste de Ucrania
porque este lugar no era seguro
Katherine y su madre reconocen que
tienen miedo y la más joven se siente
especialmente sola se quedan porque no
quieren abandonar a la bisabuela de 92
años que se niega a marcharse
me distraigo Haciendo mis deberes
Especialmente cuando tengo exámenes
virtuales es algo muy poco de casa pero
hago cosas como pintar o tejer
muchas de las mujeres en esta región
minera han tenido una vida marcada por
las dificultades
diferentes informes aseguran que la
violencia y los abusos domésticos se
duplicaron desde 2014
pero el miedo a perder lo que tienen y
las penurias económicas impiden que
busquen refugio en otra ciudad mi
salario no me permitirá alquilar un
lugar para vivir y además para pagar mis
gastos pagar por el apartamento si mi
esposo abandona el trabajo no tendremos
lo suficiente para sostenernos Irina
reconoce que hay una gran posibilidad de
que tenga que irse en algún momento su
edificio fue atacado y las ventanas
están rotas pero mientras pueden
aprietan los dientes y siguen adelante
como lo hace Alexandra que por ahora no
piensa cerrar su tienda